[Music]
we've got a couple on the phone so let's
go to Megan first what's up
Megan hey is this for real is this
actually Dr Don jalone that I'm talking
to right now no it's my
brother my brother Dan he is oh my
goodness crazy how are
you um I'm amazing right at the moment
I'm on Cloud9 um I can't even believe
I'm talking to you this is awesome thank
you for having me of course thanks for
calling in all right let's bring in Sam
husband uh I just hit I just hit line
three Sam what's up
hey just sitting in the office taking a
phone call you
know you know you guys sound like letter
Kenny it makes my heart feel so full
right now this is so great okay um so
y'all are not in the same house right
now no no okay so y'all can tell the
truth and not have to like eyeball each
other yes all right so
I don't really even know what this
Call's about so uh Megan you go first
and you say what you want to say say
what you need to say and then Sam you
hop in and then we'll go from
there okay sounds good so first thank
you your Insight and wisdom has been
life-changing in every area of my life
awesome so thank you for that um so Sam
Actually introduced me to your show back
in 2020 um and so I'm just going to
quickly go through my question makes
really no sense without the context so
for um so ever since I started listening
to your show I've been listening to
every episode to try and get tidbits
about parenting we have four kids we
have a 10-year-old daughter and three
boys that are eight six and three can I
just pause good
God yeah we both come from big families
so we both knew we wanted big families
but I don't think I was fully
prepared I wanted a basset hound forever
and then I got one the smell alone was
amazing
right oh man okay so anyway so we've
been trying to do a lot of the things
that you've suggested um and we've read
some of the books that you've suggested
too um and then outside of that we
talked to a social worker to try and get
some tools and insight to help our
eight-year-old son has ADHD okay um and
then we've also gotten him into some
classes to kind of help him get some
tools as well but despite doing all that
there's still so much fighting and
disrespect our eight-year-old continues
some days it seems like he wants to push
back about absolutely everything um he's
also can be very physically and verbally
aggressive and our six-year-old has
full-blown temper tantrums where he's
yelling and he's stomping and he's
hitting and you know we want our kids to
be open to talk about their feelings we
want them to feel safe but I'm exhausted
and I just feel like I'm a garbage can
um I just feel like some days it's all
four of them are just throwing their
crap at me and I'm just like I I don't
know what to do and so what my question
is what can Salon I do is this an us
problem is there something that we're
not doing or that we are doing we should
stop or is this just a them
[Laughter]
problem all right kind of set me up here
all right so Sam what do you
think well I mean for me the hardest
part is like I grew up in a family very
different from mine um I never ever
would say things to my mother that my
children have said to my wife and it
kind of is very difficult
to you know like not do the things my my
father did to me to my children if you
catch my drift right yeah totally and so
I'm I mean for me it's like okay I got
to do better I know I got to do better
but at the same time you know if my kids
don't listen to me when I talk nicely to
them what am I supposed to do like
like you know I I I'm at a loss for that
too where it's like you know I I I come
home from work and it's like you you
know I I really we we' worked at it
pretty good so I I rarely come home and
then the bad guy which is really nice as
a as a dad yeah absolutely but even
still you hear you hear the things and
it's like you did what yeah yeah you
know and and so then you're kind of like
now what am I supposed to even do like I
want to love my kids and I want to like
you and I do and I and I do and it's
like but I don't like when I hear these
stories right you know and so then I'm
kind of at a loss for you know how to
proceed past there yeah so let's
um to answer your question
Megan it's a complicated answer where I
like to start because it can be any
number of things okay where I like to
start
is number one one kids absorb
tension they absorb
chaos and so a 10 a eight a six and a
three is by nature chaotic right yes yes
it is so they that's in The Ether
already okay so
expecting
calm versus expecting your kids to lean
and push on every boundary is this real
is this real can I pet this tiger I
wonder if this dog will bite me let's
lick a snake let's like you know like
that's what kids are supposed to do okay
yeah and so often there's a tension
because I have this picture of my kids
all like one doing a puzzle one coloring
and one I don't I don't want those kids
I'll just say it that way right yeah I
also I don't want my house like the way
it is right now and there so there's a
gap that Gap is for me the adult okay
that's step one y often I will tell a
mom who's staying at home with four kids
are you homeschooling too or are they
going to school oh goodness no they're
going to
school all right yeah no we we did that
covid and I realized very quickly no no
no we're not that's not a thing in our
house that yes I had a very similar
experience in my house so
um so it's very important that you Mom
do what you have to do during the day
when the kids are gone to take care of
yourself and that is unfortunately you
got to find some places where you can
move your body you got to find some
places where you have some adult women
friends and that might mean we're going
to get a sitter for the three-year-old
or if the three-year-old goes to like a
preschool I don't know what it's what
youall have in Canada but if there's
some sort of preschool thing or a a
sitter of some sort um but I have to
have these things built into my life cuz
what I'm trying to do is take my water
glass and pour out as much water as I
can before those four kids get home and
start trying to test everything all at
the same time because they're going to
be dumping water into that glass and so
I want it as empty as
possible yeah okay I don't know what
that looks like for y'all that's for you
and Sam to figure out okay um yeah
that's step one we're going to lower the
temperature in the house with what we
can contr step two both Sam and
Megan I'm not a fan of this gentle
parenting idea your kids don't get to
hit each other period they don't get to
be disrespectful they don't get to
scream and yell and holler and whatever
okay where I do hold the kids
responsible is I say because you did X
you have
chosen to separate from this team for a
minute and it's usually one minute per
year that is one of the things that we
have been doing is we have changed our
language to be if you are choosing this
Behavior you are choosing whatever the
consequences and then starts the
explosion where it's like okay are you
if you're going to choose to yell at me
you're choosing to go to your room and
then it's like no I'm not going to my
room and it's like I literally have to
pick the child and take them to the room
like because now it's getting to be like
okay now we've escalated things you you
do need to leave the room and cool down
and it's so in some ways it's like we
have been doing that but it in some ways
almost escalates things especially with
um with their 8-year-old or six-year-old
so here's the missing here's the missing
piece there it does
require entry into the room with the
kid yeah and this statement or this
series of of
statements I know your body feels so big
and on fire right now and you look him
in the eye and you say and these
feelings don't make me
scared I know that you don't want to be
feeling this big I know
that and I'm going to be safe more than
anything in the world I want you right
by my side in this kitchen helping me
cook I want you right at the counter
working on your homework so we can laugh
and tell
jokes but when you have these big
feelings and you choose to
hit you choose to not be in there and we
don't work as a family when you choose
to not be there right so for an ADHD kid
I'll speak to that one the most
terrifying thing they can experience
experiences
isolation right and unfortunately the
way they show that terror is to make
themselves almost impossible to be in
relationship
with and so I'm going to head directly
into the middle of
that chaos and I'm going to be as calm
as humanly possible what they're
desperate for is are you still going to
love me still going to love me still
going to love me yes I will not abandon
you but you can choose to walk away from
us right so that is easier said than
done when you have three other kids
going a
right I totally get
that but there is a heading into it and
being very clear about I know your body
feels big do either one of you have have
ADHD symptoms or I don't know if been
diagnosed with
it yes okay yes that would be me and and
I'm on meds for it so okay um Sam I I
will will honor my kids and not use say
who I had this conversation with but I I
sat down with one of my kids when they
were very young and said you and I have
very very special
brains we have very special brains that
allow us to feel really
big sometimes feelings that aren't even
real and sometimes those feelings feel
scary and
it also allows us to sit with other
people when they're hurting too which
makes us such a gift to our community
and to our families and so here's what I
did I walked
through what I did is I made sure my kid
felt not
alone and years later after that one
single
conversation um and we also came up with
a secret hand signal which is to point
to my
head or to point to my chest
that that child refers back to that
conversation you know I've got big
feelings I know and they don't scare me
at all and I'm so glad that you have
them you cannot talk to your mom like
that right and so there was this piece
that allowed my kid to see okay he goes
to work every day and gets a
paycheck and also I'm just like
him and also see what I'm saying like it
was social norming going on inside the
house yeah um also there's things like
Physical Therapy a lot of ADHD kids need
to bang into other
things they they stomp through the house
really hard they they got sensory issues
and sometimes something as simple as
physical therapy can be such a gift to a
kid learning how to oh I don't have to
hit the ground that hard right I don't
have to squeeze my pencil that tight um
and some of those things are are really
helpful you'all may have tried some of
those things what about the six-year-old
the six-year-old does not um Al we're
aware of he doesn't have a lot of the
this like similar things at least that
we've noticed with our eight-year-old
and our 8-year-old like we pretty much
noticed it like early on um it was like
we hit the two-year-old Tantrums at 18
months with their eight-year-old and it
just never stopped
surey think about this think about this
that body feels like it's on
fire yeah yeah our six-year-old I'm not
sure it's I've noticed I I do wonder if
it's just you know so he's the in the
middle of the three
boys and you know we have our
three-year-old who he's three so you
know is a six-year-old a girl no a boy
three boys at the end yeah our
daughter's the oldest okay is she mean
or is she nice she's wonderful
absolutely amazing okay can I tell you
where that can be a
problem yes your kids your other three
boys know
that right
they have to know that they're wonderful
too yes they're just wonderful
different yeah and I mean yeah and again
I feel like again we've been trying like
we've done things like you know the
journal writing the journal and of
course which is hard when the kids are
still learning how they're just they're
just drawing pictures yeah yeah do you
um have you all tried the the weekly
breakfast
together no we haven't done that I that
one's what we have been doing is every
um so there's three days in the week
each kid gets a turn staying up a little
a little bit later not super late but a
little bit later with either Samurai and
we do something like play games or have
a tea party or um whatever the thing is
okay um so that they all get that little
bit and they they look forward to it
every week like it's definitely like a
thing um and it's been great because
that that just seems to work best the
hard part is I also work part time and
I'm a nurse in a long-term care facility
so I work
evenings um and every other weekend so
it's challenging to sometimes scheduling
wise as well and I mean Sam has to be at
work at like he leaves at 700 so then
it's hard to get you know all those
pieces right it's trying to figure out
what works best with our life right now
there you go so I would recommend
strongly and y'all y'all may do this
already I would recommend you and
Sam um by the way you said samurai and
that sounds kind of awesome just have to
shout out that um you and Sam once a
week I want yall to plan out not what
works indefinitely what works this
week I want to make sure you and Sam's
marriage is
Ironclad budget wise sexually connect
connection because managing all four
kids and doing something cool like
everybody gets to stay up a little later
we get to do tea parts you could do
something like this suddenly the
relationship that's going off the rails
is y'all two
there is some seasonality to this and
what I mean by seasonality is your
10-year-old is about to turn 11 12 and
13 and she's going to change
dramatically your eight-year-old is
going to move into middle school he's
going to change
dramatically like he's just going to
start turning fourth and fifth grade and
then suddenly sixth grade and there's
going to be a dramatic
shift you're six in and down the line so
you're about to hit some major
Milestones
here one last thing with your eight and
your six-year-old that I would recommend
I think the 10-year-old everybody needs
not just a job but they need a role a
purpose a
gift they need to understand what they
bring to the
family and so that's not always fun and
there's a lot of hey to my son Hank go
back out and get the chickens or they
dogs have to eat and like oh jeez dad
come on so it's not like it's perfect
every
time but my son knows he's got a very
particular not just chores but he's got
a a pillar that the house sits on my
daughter too and that's been tough
because it would be way way way faster
for my wife to cook dinner by
herself and when my daughter feels like
she's participating in making dinner the
whole experience is Magic there's no
yelling there's no screaming there's no
fighting there's no none of the because
she is locked in relationally and locked
in with a
purpose so sit back with your husband
and say okay what's this week what
purpose can we give each one of these
kids this week when it comes to dinner
when it comes to this when it comes to
all right I'm going to be having to go
to work and so we're going to make sure
we wake up and have X and Y and Z maybe
we're going to hire a middle school kid
to come over and play with the
six-year-old and the three-year-old on
Saturday mornings with Mom's at work
we're going to pay three bucks an hour
or whatever it is we're going to begin
to look at all the relational touch
points none of this is easy and every
kid is different um I have seen some
pretty remarkable stuff from parenting
expert and she goes by Dr Becky on
Instagram she has some really great
stuff um I haven't been through her
courses but it's got rave reviews um and
she has a particular um level of
expertise on something she calls a
deeply feeling kid that might be
something worth looking into um again
she goes by Dr Becky deeply feeling kids
um if you have an eight-year-old that
just feels like their body's electric on
fire some really good stuff there um but
let me be super
clear your kids aren't allowed to hit I
will remove you and yes there is a point
when I am bigger than you I will pick
you up and move you out of this
room and you you have to be careful with
a deeply feeling kid or a kid that is
wrestling with these wild emotions
because that in some ways gives them
exactly what they
want
connection time one-on-one attention
laser focus from Mom and
Dad so where can I give time and
attention and laser focus and
connectivity to that kid that is
positive in nature not responsive in
nature that's hard when you got four of
them running around
it's
hard and Sam I know as somebody who
struggles with this you walk home and
you are so overwhelmed being lasered in
all day you just want to go let's do
nothing doing nothing for a 10 an eight
and a six and a three yearold is a
recipe for chaos it's pulling the fence
down and letting them just run a muck
and they go crazy and they trip and fall
hit their
heads so it's coming home and choosing
I'm going to laser back in also with
that
8-year-old um sometimes it's good just
hey we're going to go for a long long
walk
we're going to go to the creek we're
going to go to the park we're going to
go do a thing do we have time to do that
no do we have stuff we got to do at home
yes and we're going to plug in and that
still doesn't mean we're not going to
have a fight at bedtime but we're going
to do this again and I'm going to show
up again and I'm going to show up again
what you're going to see over time is
the Bedtime stuff starts to minimize the
fights start to minimize the chaos in
the house slowly comes down but here's
the question Sam and Megan I want y'all
to ask I want youall to ask this
question
every Sunday night
together I want you to ask this question
how can I love you this week what do I
need from you this week how can we
minimize chaos in the house this
week just ask that question and see if
there's if there's money stress see if
there's relational stress see if there
is we need to put sex on the calendar
see if there is we need to go on a date
night see if there is what do we need to
do in this house we need to go exercise
what do we need to do in this house to
begin to minimize the chaos that the
kids might be touching the electric
fence and getting
burned and don't fail to use the
resources at your local school you pay
for them you'll get them you're in it
guys you're in it that's a whole bunch
of ideas every kid's gonna be
different make sure your kids know
they're connected make sure they know
they've got a
part